well guys there really is no other day
to be reviewing a movie like
Independence Day because it's
Independence Day so let's talk about
Independence Day Independence Day came
out in 1996 and for people my age back
then it was pretty much the next star
war so I mean for kids at that time it
was the greatest thing ever made now
it's sort of like this awesomely fun 90s
thing that you're sort of nostalgic
about and you feel like yeah I remember
the good old days of Independence Day
and Stargate definitely helped roland
emmerich get more attention but this is
really the movie that put him on the map
and then he made Godzilla but this movie
stars Will Smith Jeff Goldblum Bill
Pullman and these guys essentially are
dealing with the alien apocalypse aliens
are going all over the world giant ships
are evaporating all of the cities and we
got Jeff Goldblum as the smart guy who
uses computers to try to figure out
what's going on real Smith is more
badass type wants to get in there and
get it done and blast them you know yes
welcome to earth now that was a close
encounter and Bill Pullman is the
president that's right Bill Pullman is
the president of the United States it's
pretty awesome actually and it kind of
was one of the first movies that started
that big fun summer action thing that
combined did extreme patriotism with a
lot of explosions it was like Roland
Emmerich kind of started the whole
Michael Bay trend that eventually went
through Armageddon and deep impact and
all the big summer fun movies where
mankind has to come together to try to
survive an event and then at the end
it's like yes patriotism is so amazing
but this movie had a fun vibe to it and
it's not just the nostalgia like Jeff
Goldblum in this movie was awesome
Jeff Goldblum in the 90s was Jeff
Goldblum in the 90s he was Ian Malcolm
in Jurassic Park and here he is an
Independence Day rocking the hair
rocking the glasses doing all the Jeff
Goldblum isms I give it a cold the only
thing missing from Independence Day was
Will Smith doing a rap song during the
ending credits that would have made it
the absolute best movie ever made
don't get me wrong I recognize that
Independence Day is a very cheesy movie
and it's filled with your classic 90s
cheese and the big Bill Pullman speech
today will be our independent
stay the dog running away from the
explosions and surviving and a little
kid who likes his dad he just wants to
see it's all very cheesy but
entertaining because this movie actually
understands that you can actually tell
that as the movie progresses you can
really see that they're not trying to go
overly serious this film is cheesy fun
guilty-pleasure
summer entertainment from start to
finish that's one of the reasons why it
still works for me today as an adult
because I've actually watched a lot of
films as an adult that I loved as a kid
nowadays and I don't like them anymore
it's not just the novelty of the fact
that it came out when I was younger it
does understand what it's trying to do
and it does it pretty well
for its time the special effects were
incredible nowadays some of it does look
dated but it's really the characters of
Will Smith and Jeff Goldblum
particularly for me anyway Goldblum that
make this movie more entertaining to
watch and Bill Pullman is a fun
president you know you get that scene
where he goes to area 51 he didn't
actually know area 51 existed but now
he's in area 51 and Dana's down there in
area 51 and he's just he loves these
creatures so much and Bill Coleman's
like you know one of these creatures
destroyed an entire population why are
you making fun of this event there's
great jazz everywhere killing people I'm
the President of the United States damn
it that was my Bill Pullman impression
but like I said Jeff Goldblum
continuously makes his movie awesome for
me because he treated it as serious as
you really could take it like he was
taking the material seriously yeah he's
got all of his little Jeff Goldblum isms
in there which makes it even better but
he just he really took his character
seriously and I like that about him you
know that early scene when this guy is
chasing him dag I like to call my mother
oh we have to call my lawyer
oh forget yeah like gonna be really hard
to take that seriously when you're Jeff
Goldblum you're like I'm this serious
actor and this guy's following me around
oh my god hey and it's fun to watch Will
Smith and the pilots go after the big
UFO mothership and try to take it out
it's a lot of fun this movie's fun but
like I said it recognizes itself for
what it is and so for that reason I'm
still able to relish it as an adult
Independence Day for me is still a fun
science fiction movie it's a big messy
loud bloated adventure but in all the
right ways in my opinion I'm gonna give
it a penance day and a - so guys I'm
gonna be doing this review also with my
good buddy
John the flick pic and I'm also gonna be
going over to his house pretty soon in a
couple days and we're gonna make a lot
of collaboration videos together we're
gonna be talking about each x-men film
before the Wolverine comes out and we're
gonna be doing that together at his
place soon also gonna be doing some
audio commentaries on films and some
other interesting videos as well so I
hope you guys enjoy that
here's Jon's review of Independence Day
oh my gosh I gotta kill my brother I
gotta call my housekeeper I gotta call
my lawyer
forget my lawyer I also have to review
Independence Day
[Music]
so much like the way the movie
Independence Day goes down when forces
unite to take down an alien invasion
being my pal Chris Duckman are going to
come together to review this movie so
you're gonna get two reviews for the
same movie okay so the big summer action
flick Independence Day where aliens come
to earth and Will Smith and Jeff
Goldblum have to save the day now let me
give you my quick back story about
Independence Day I remember it like it
was yesterday it was the summer of 1996
me my stepdad went to the movie theater
there was a bucket of popcorn between
both of us I had a cherry Pepsi I don't
remember what he had and when I was
watching this movie up on the big screen
I was just blown away you know they had
all these big special effects but the
great thing about the special effects in
Independence Day is it was a mid-1990s
movie and they didn't completely rely on
CGI yeah it wasn't quite up to par so
they had to do all these practical
effects and old-school effects and they
blended them all together so well in
this movie and that's something that
always stood out to me you're talking
about line of sight because in
Independence Day we have special effects
and miniatures that craftsmen put
together and actually brought the magic
of filmmaking to life
we didn't rely on computers to do a
sloppy mess what you're talking about is
a virus we go into the alien spacecraft
and we essentially give it the the cold
yeah okay that's my Jeff Goldblum
impression it went on a little bit too
long anyway speaking of Jeff Goldblum
Jeff Goldblum is one of the main stars
of this movie and Jeff Goldblum has such
a scream presence about him I just
really like the guy you know he has
bizarre weird speech patterns but I'd
like that that's what makes him stand
out in this movie and that's something
to say about this movie everyone in this
movie though they're cliched at times
and a little bit one-dimensional they're
all likable and memorable too and that
says something about the movie
Independence Day because the movie has
all these over-the-top zany comedic
moments but they blend them so well in
this summer blockbuster action movie
then you really buy into it doesn't come
across as overly cliche even though
that's what it is but it blends all
these things together so well you just
buy into it in this movie Jeff
Goldblum's character plays like the
technology expert guy he's the one who
figures out everything the aliens are
going to do before they do it the movie
also stars The Fresh Prince Will Smith
and this is one of his first movies that
really skyrocketed him into being that
summer action hero
so Will Smith's character in the smooth
plays an Air Force pilot who also is
dating a stripper yeah for some odd
reason his girlfriend still stripping
even though it doesn't seem necessary
but maybe she just likes to dance I
don't know but you gotta love Will Smith
in the movie welcome to earth and that's
just one of the many one-liners that
this movie contains and there's
something about this movie this movie
gets away with a lot of things you broke
any one of these things off you'd be
like that stupid but when you throw it
all together in that Independence Day
movie it's just like yeah that's pretty
cool and entertaining the movie also
stars Randy Quaid as a drunk crop-duster
I've said enough the basic premise of
Independence Day is you have all these
different storylines going on throughout
the movie and at the end of the movie
they all kind of converged into one to
defeat the aliens we are going to live
on we are going to survive today is our
Independence Day that's my Bill Pullman
impression who plays the president in
the movie so Independence Day is that
big is that stupid is that over-the-top
does it have several script issues that
just don't make any sense and things
that you really have to stretch your
imagination even buy into yeah but is it
a fun time is it a big epic action
popcorn movie that really delivers on
that entertaining factor and you just
get immersed into the movie well for me
it is and because of that and because
it's one of my childhood classics I
guess you could say I'm going to give
Independence Day in any - okay so that's
my take on Independence Day and by the
way speaking of alien invasions and
about a week or so my good pal Chris
Duckman is gonna be stopping by we're
gonna be doing some collab projects and
by collab projects I mean running around
in my basement wearing Batman masks
screaming like little girls and then we
watch over the top on blu-ray
[Music]